hey it's Evan every week I like to thank
someone was that an impact on my
business was believed in me was helped
me because we can't do this alone right
you cannot do this business alone and
even if you're on your own you have
people who believe when you who support
you encourage you and so take the time
to thank them you could do it with a
note a video an email whatever so I like
to do a video today I'd like to thank
Christina Christina is my video editor
and I found her when I was I was in
crisis mode my video editor who was
working with me disappear don't know
where he went and I had all these videos
and I had to get them up and and I
wasn't a good video editor and so she
came on board and as part of the job
interview process she went above and
beyond I I gave maybe 20 people a trial
job and said you know make make this
video put some heart into would make it
what you think would be great and she
really put a lot of herself into it she
added effects should an intro she added
music she went above what anybody else
did and I hired her right she she did a
great job but and since then the videos
have gotten better she has added a love
of quality that I didn't have before and
it's helping reach more people uh she
gives me suggestions for what to do for
the videos and tags them and sorts them
and just overall is great I love having
people on my team who who not only do
their job but think of other ways that
they can help but think of ways to make
things better because they care right
you want people who care who aren't just
doing their job to make money but who
actually care about what's being made
and that's Christina so Christina I know
you're watching this because you get
your editing this thank you so much for
all the great work it's been fantastic
having you on the team and I'm looking
forward to many more years of working
together for those of you guys watching
take time this week and just say thank
you you know you did not get here on
your own somebody has helped you
recognize them make them feel good about
it and they'll feel good you feel good
too and they'll be one of the highlights
of your week so do it homework first for
this week get out and thing
somebody believe those you watching like
the video thumbs up below you guys want
to see more you have a question you have
a comment leave it below I'll make a
video response thank you guys thank you
so much and I'll see you soon